[Applause]
you-you-you forgot to mention the tough
questions but you said we were going to
have a chat I didn't know it was going
to be tough so yeah there you go
thank you for coming I hope this will be
worth your evening and yeah we're gonna
have some time for you as well to ask
questions so please bring the tough one
so I think that's what matters there too
if you will need yes he has mints for me
so I told me every time I answer a
question okay I can have one of those so
that's what's happening now the one mint
prize so how many of you have read
software happy okay cool
and how many of you know have seen like
Mohs any of his videos those viral
videos I got circulated how many of you
guys saw them yeah yeah like
over half got to see that video yeah the
video is always part a big part of I
mean books don't reach a billion right I
mean if I if I if a book reaches a
billion people that's that beats Jesus
we're not aiming for that right but no
but the idea really of the of the
mission is to spread online through
video so thank you for for having
watched them and hopefully you're
spreading the message on that yeah I
think something that I really
appreciated that you said in the book
that I've learned from you is that that
this this happiness pot of gold is not
at the end of the rainbow of achievement
but rather it's along the journey in the
present moment along the journey it's
almost a mindset along the journey yeah
it's so so one of the biggest myths of
the modern world is that and I say that
with love and respect we've productized
everything we've even productized
happiness it's like it's really really
funny because that pot of gold that's
called happiness was actually at the
beginning of the journey so you were
born happy right every child you've ever
seen every infant you've ever seen if
they get their basic needs for survival
they're happy right and then we run out
of happiness it's not the other way
around right but yet the
cause everything to us now is sort of
the material the material view of the
world we think that happiness is
something that we should acquire we
should strive for we should work hard to
to achieve
it's almost like we've earned it like
we've done our share of hard work and
now we deserve to be happy when you were
a child you didn't have to do anything
to be happy right you didn't even need
anything from outside you to be happy
now that myth is in my view the biggest
enemy of happiness in the modern world
it is it's almost as if we come to a
point where we don't think we deserve it
anymore as a matter of fact a lot a lot
of us even believe that if we are happy
we're doing something wrong maybe we're
not trying hard enough
right you know some some some northern
European culture you know it's so
against the idea that if you smile at
someone in the street they'll think that
something is wrong with you right and in
a very interesting way if you if you go
to work and appear to be very happy your
boss will go like are we paying him too
much you know it's like what's wrong
what's wrong with this right it's like
we've started to tell ourselves no no no
we should not be happy and so we started
to delay it we started to say when I
have achieved the other more important
priorities then I have earned the right
to be happy
what what priority is more important as
like when you when you really think
about it aren't you trying to achieve
all of this so that you become happy so
why why the middleman why do you have to
take a step on the way why don't you
just solve directly for happy there's
there's two things that I think are
really important to unpack there first
is the child I think that that's really
important to unpack there and then the
other thing is the kind of the balance
that we can strike between wanting to
achieve our goals and setting forth and
I have a goal I've written it down I'm
going to achieve it but not being super
tied to that to the outcome not we're
not relying or happiness on that outcome
but rather on the journey maybe of
getting to that goal so let's start with
that latter one the one that I just said
yeah so this actually is so one of the
things that
I that I really really try to achieve
with software happy and what my entire 1
billion happy mission is is as a as an
as a thought that we are here for a
reason right we're we're we're traveling
the physical world in this physical form
to make a difference right each of us in
his own or her own very different way so
some of us might make a difference by
developing a piece of code others might
make a difference by raising a wonderful
child or sharing a piece of knowledge or
even just smiling in someone's face and
changing the world that way right
yet that conviction that to have an
impact on life you have to pay
unhappiness as the tax to get there is
wrong right so this this work is an
attempt not to say let's find happiness
the Eat Pray Love way like you know you
don't have to go to an ashram and live
life to achieve that happiness but
rather you know find happiness on the
path to impact right and surprisingly
the best path to impact is actually to
be happy there is so much research that
will tell you that happy people are a
lot more productive than unhappy people
12% 1% specifically is the statistic but
it's also you know it's also not that's
that's measuring their own productivity
its measured and it's not measuring the
productivity that the impact that they
have on others around them right if
you're a happy customer service employee
your customers are happy you're you know
your business is better if you you know
if you're happy you make your colleagues
happy they add a little bit of their 12
percent everything starts to roll from
there now you know I worked at Google
for years and people would think that
you know we we have game rooms and we
offer coffees and sushi because we're
nice no no it's we you know Google was
very wise to to make to create an
environment where people are happy happy
people are more productive they commit
more to what they work on
they you know they report less absent
leaves they don't change jobs as often
they don't complain about other benefits
and perks because they enjoy what
they're doing right it's the wise thing
to do
happiness is not a luxury on and it's
not a luxury in our relationship and
it's not a luxury when we raise our
children and and that's the biggest
biggest biggest issue we have is that we
you know we were talking before we we
came here about the world that we live
in today that is a result of the Great
Depression and World War two of
everything that you live in today that
enormous greed that enormous
competitiveness the individual focus is
just a big trauma that our grandparents
went through and and then decided you
know what I don't want you to ever
suffer like I did and and the insurance
policy I'm gonna give you is called
success right let's go out there and
make sure that you're successful that so
that you'll never really suffer right
and and as we try to chase that success
we ignore everything that matters and
you know we ignore the path we ignore
this moment which is a wonderful moment
regardless of if you make a hundred
dollars at the end of the month or a
billion dollars at the end of your life
by the way even when you do get there
you're gonna go like ah just a billion
maybe I should just kill myself for
another five years and make another
billion and I've seen that so often it's
just delusional it's it's just constant
striving for something you don't need to
buy things that you don't want to
impress people that you don't like like
yeah yeah will I really want to talk
about the conspicuous consumption I
think we'll talk about that in culture
as you mentioned what's been going on
for the last 70 or so years let's maybe
talk about the child oh yeah they're so
something that I love loved as a way of
understanding the the child is that the
child's aperture for signal for love and
for learning is massive when the child's
born and then culture does things that
slowly closes this aperture to the
signal on this love wouldn't know what
it tell us tell us more about the child
and about yeah so let's please do that
experiment I mean just just I I actually
am writing a simplified version for
Seoul for happy now and one of the
exercises I as I'm saying go and babysit
right
watch watch children that's a wonderful
exercise yeah right if you go and watch
children you would see them they're
lying on their back right they you know
as long as they as I said they have
their basic needs for survival which by
the way includes love right so they have
they're fed they're safe they're warm
and so on and they're loved and and and
and watch what they do they lie there on
their back and they giggle they're full
of joy full of joy they just look at the
ceiling it's like seriously what's so
interesting about but the child is just
constantly staring at nothing and
totally in total joy when they're not
pooping and screaming and yelling that's
really interesting no but but that's
actually quite interesting because when
a diaper gets wet okay right the child
gets unhappy right you change the diaper
you remove the reason for unhappiness
that child goes back to its default
setting right it's literally the like
you like your mobile phone right you get
you take it out of the box and it works
perfectly well for the first day right
so the battery lasts a full day only
that first day right and then what
happens is you start to install weird
absent and that's really truly what
happens to us as children they start
especially San Francisco installed oh
say your dad I mean I I love you guys
but it's not about it's like really the
more Western we become the more
influenced we are by the illusions of
the modern world and those illusions
include things like the shape of your
body matters the way people think about
you matters you know that that success
is measured in in material possessions
that this is the only way to measure
success and by the way it doesn't matter
how much you have what matters is that
you have more than your neighbor right
you don't have to score an A you have to
score an A better than your sister right
and and you know it's like why like
seriously I mean my wonderful son Ali
came to me at a point in time and I said
Ali you should score a man
in mathematics you're good in
mathematics and he said Papa why why do
you want me to score an A I said because
you're good at it
and he went like yeah yeah but why isn't
a important if I'm good at it why do you
want an A right and I struggled a little
bit and he said okay let me help you
here do you want me to learn math and be
amazing at it and score a B or do you
want me to not learn math and score an A
which of those is better for you good
question great question and I was like
yeah why do I care so much about mold
that they put us in while the reality is
all I want is that my son learns
mathematics right and by the way I don't
I know that I didn't want him to learn
geography even though every parent will
say hey you know you need to score an A
in everything too much too much and take
that and understand how we treat our
children right they're born happy they
stay happy until we mess up right we
send them to school and we say hey you
remember that playful joyful thing no
more right six hours a day we want you
to sit in this place don't open your
mouth whatever junk the teacher says not
and say yes right if you believe that
what the teacher is telling you is not
right don't object because that's not a
good way to to score right to get an A
and what do we do everyone some of us
resist and we're rebellious and we take
a few weeks of saying nah oh I still
want to play right and then we all
submit and we all go like yeah who wants
to play it's like it's causing me too
much trouble who wants to be you know
playful who wants to be fun let's just
get serious serious you're six like well
where did that come from
right and we and we take that and we
follow through through the rest of our
lives
one of my most eye-opening experiences
when I joined Google you know was there
ten things we knew to be true with one
of them was you can be serious without a
suit right and there is a very
interesting difference between being
between serious or grumpy if you want
and committed they're not one and the
same somehow people said hey you
to be serious yeah the serious equal
grumpy or the serious equal committed
right I'm committed I can show up at
work and put my heart in it but smile
and hug my team and you know we have a
good time and we have fun and we'd love
it isn't that better than just going out
there and going applause
do your work oh what's that we're all
little children inside yes and I hope
Pablo Picasso talked about the
importance of retaining a childhood
throughout in the rest of you I believe
it or not so as I said I'm working on
several other works now I have 8 pages
in that new piece of work that reminds
you how to become a child it's funny
that's good it's funny they give us a
lot a little spoiler a little bubblegum
ice cream it's like you know I'm sorry I
love California but like seriously those
brownies are horrible like you know the
the ones with what Chia and like sand
and have fun enjoy life right I'm by the
way I'm not saying go all the way to the
other extreme mmm only brownies and ice
cream no no but but but but but you know
when was the last time you ran around
with your children in a park or with
your friends in a park where when did
you actually go to the gym to enjoy it
right we go to the gym to deliver
another target
it's really weird like we're running an
algorithm rather than enjoying the
problem yeah we we forgot about joy we
are so driven so driven we are so
self-critical we are so unhappy with
where we are even though I will tell you
if you're in this room you're one of the
luckiest point 1 percent of the people
on the face of this planet right and hey
you may have to spend the next 40 years
of your life to become one of the
luckiest point or 1% of the people on
this planet but don't forget that you're
luckier than light
important 9% of everyone who lives right
so why are we striving so hard why don't
we just make a difference to the world
without really being grumpy about it why
why is it that we I'm talking too much
why why is it that we are so unable to
enjoy the blessings that we've been
given when it is abundant to the point
that it is almost impossible to count
III would urge you to do that exercise
yeah I would urge you to count the
number of blessings that you have that a
person in Syria today does not have have
yeah it will blow you away I mean I
sometimes have people complaining about
their life and I would say okay I want
you to do me a favor I want you to wait
until January and then walk the streets
of prayer in San Francisco or New York
find a homeless person and complain
about what you just told me about yes if
you find it in your heart to do that to
to repeat one of those you know modern
world problems to them then it's a real
problem
I frequently spend time thinking about
what it's like to live in the shoes of
people that are much less fortunate than
I am and I think that helps a lot with
having gratitude for the circumstances
that I do live in and this is all
different types of experiments
everything from what would it be like to
not have electricity what would it be
like to not have clean water or a
shelter over your head or constant
warfare going around or around you and
that when we really immerse ourselves in
those life experiences I think it
changes us for the better makes us more
grateful for what we do have you touched
on the importance of just having an ice
cream and really enjoying it and being
in the park and just really enjoying it
rather than treating it like an
algorithm of needing to take your kids
to the park and just be frown but rather
go and run and play and take a frisbee
and dance and and when you're walking on
the streets
do your best to smile and you'll change
the way that other people's days are
going by doing something
as simple as just smiling on the street
mo you mentioned culture over the last
70 years and I really wanna to unpack
this in a little more detail and how it
applies to children especially now the
conspicuous consumption era has its
everywhere now
I'm your and you're in your book this
the story that mo teaches you about is
that very financially successful and oh
you answered a question I was doing to
us can I get a minute
so and so financially successful and
then the process of of wanting to you
see and you're in Dubai Dubai how many I
don't know how many of you have been to
Dubai but when you're in Dubai you see
extraordinary wealth extraordinary
wealth in Dubai and you go I'm gonna
with click with a couple clicks I'm
gonna buy a Rolls Royce and the moment
the rules of rice are landed you weren't
any happier and this sort of consumptive
process of I don't wear jewelry and I
don't want to wear jewelry I don't like
the vibe other people like the vibe and
they can they can choose that to be
their vibe but there is a certain reason
for that and I think that if there is
some sort of a process of consumption
that we get used to once you get a
one-bedroom apartment you want a
two-bedroom apartment then you want
three then you want a house and you want
two cars not just one car so what what
do we do because so much of the culture
around us is pushing these milestones in
our face what do we what do we do in
return you find out what you really want
how many of us actually spend time to
introspect and say okay that didn't work
the idea of consuming so much is because
we have been taught that material
possessions are gonna make us happy so
you buy a car and for somewhere around
20 to 70 seconds you go like ah I made
it right and then you sit behind the
wheel and regardless of what car it is
what do you look at
you look at the road right it doesn't
really matter at all which car you are
in unless it serves your ego right which
basically is the reason why people buy
expensive cause it's like to tell the
rest of the world that you made it now I
will tell you hands down if you really
have made it you will realize that this
urge goes away it's like and you know
unless you haven't made it and so you're
trying to lie to the world and I might
as well tell you
save your money until you make it right
but that's not the point the point is
we're consuming because of because of a
vicious circle we we buy something it
gives us that jolt of happiness for 20
seconds and then it goes away and we
start to say instead of saying that
whatever it is that we bought has no
inherent value of happiness in it we say
ah it's because we didn't buy the right
one right if I buy a better car I'll
probably find happiness there right so
you buy a better car and then you just
get that jolt for 60 seconds and then
you go like ah it went away because it's
not read if I'm voted in red I would be
happier
right and you keep chasing and chasing
surprisingly stupid enough to never stop
and say is that that's not found in cars
like seriously when I was a child lying
on my back I didn't have a car and I was
happy right so is happiness not found
there and when you make that just little
pause to think hmm
suddenly you realize what it is that's
not serving you in life
the problem becomes bigger we're
destroying our planet I don't know if
you know the statistics there are a
billion people around the world that are
obese and a billion people around the
world that are starving to death our
world is not lacking resources were just
so abusive so abusive and so
irresponsible that we you know there are
all of those talks about we're not going
to leave anything for our children no no
it is a lot more urgent
than that in a you know in some years
from now you're not gonna have enough
for you you know this is a big trick of
the exponential function
you know how the question of if if a jar
is is you know has ten percent in it and
it's doubling every year or every five
years every doubling you know fills more
as much as as as is full already how
much time how much how many more
doublings if you're already of your at
fifty percent it's not five or ten or 50
more doublings it's just one more and
we're so close in so many ways the least
of which the least noticed of which is
depression i mean you've seen the recent
the recent events and it's so sad it
kills me one of every four people you
will in turn interact with in san
francisco it's clinically depressed
they're not talking about it right but
they're clinically and these are the
people that actually found it in their
heart and found the resources to go and
get diagnosed to the point that they're
actually clinically diagnosed depressed
there are so many that are unhappy and
we're all sucking it in and saying well
i'm fine right
you know the typical answer is like how
are you today and you go like i'm just
fine right i actually pause when someone
asks me how are you today i say let me
think about it
i actually feel quite calm a little a
bit you know worried about the
conversation and a little bit
sleep-deprived that that kind of
awareness is a call for me to actually
understand how i feel right
the problem is the following one in
every four is clinically depressed
teen suicide is at an all-time high
suicide in general is at an all-time
high and we're not even addressing the
problem right our planet's resources are
depleted they're more and more depleted
and we're not even addressing the
problem you wrote in your book our
tendency to to be driven towards
negativity to have negative thoughts be
the ones there what is it the there
seventy percent and then 62% of
all words related to emotion are
negative are negative and then the way
that the way that you just described
culture and civilization there's a
there's a there's a plateau you write
about as well that I think is important
to highlight there are so many people
depressed suicide there's a plateau of
income that you earn per year about
70,000 or so is this plateau because
then you can buy all the necessities you
need shelter food water education health
care and then after that it's applied
seventy thousand dollars plateaus
happiness the the thought about the
about for example like Anthony Bourdain
something that I read that I really
wanted to share that I thought was
really important was it's not about what
you live but it's about how you live it
and that really resonates because if we
just choose that all these experiences
that we live however we how we live
these experiences as with love of the
present moment and a love of just life
then it changes a lot of the way that we
live in a lot of the way that other
people live well maybe this is something
that might pique your interest because
we talk about the planet we talk about
we talked about with resource depleting
there seems to be a drive with the
millennial generation and with the
generations II seems to be driven to the
shared economy we're now doing things
more for the Instagram you can rent a
dress for a day or you can go and have
an experience at like the ice cream
factory or whatever from a stream using
for a day you can rent a car a nice car
for one day and you get the experience
and you take an Instagram photo and
that's it and it's a shared economy in
that sense
mm-hm so we seem to be transitioning in
some ways in the right direction not at
all okay I know that into it for the
Instagram thing is not it's not
I was discussing this with a friend
yesterday you know the proper way to
solve a problem or to actually set an
intention or whatever it is starts with
the Y then the what then the ha shared
economy is solve is offering a different
how for the wrong way for the wrong what
what is the Y then so here's the
question why do we dress why do we buy
clothes probably shame we say maybe
there is a bit of decency for the human
for I don't have as much of that shame
as other people but there is so so your
city is cold for this time of the year
just so that you know all right
okay warmth warmth was there you know
this is one of them right the the other
is you really want to to you know cover
yourself somehow right oh that will be
comparing size of genitals than oh my no
we don't want to do that and bad image
now the the the question is is that why
you buy clothes you want to buy a car to
move from A to Z right from A to B it's
that why you choose a specific car you
want to buy a phone to browse the
Internet and answer calls is that why
you do it now
consumption most of our consumption is
ego driven it's not need driven at all
right we consume not because we need we
consume because we want to show the
others a side of our self that is true
or not
now if you fix the why you wouldn't need
a different huh so why would need to be
for need rather than for ego so so what
one of the you know exercises I discuss
which gets a lot of positive feedback in
salt for a P is an exercise I call
undress so so understand there is a
utility to ego there is a utility to ego
if you actually I go here is not defined
as arrogance ego is defined as your
as an identity that you assume for
yourself and you want the world to
understand as you write so I am an
engineer gives has a utility when I tell
you that you understand that this book
is not gonna tell you to say all right
if I was a spiritual leader I you would
understand that this might be about the
spiritual practice if I tell you I am an
engineer you understand there are going
to be equations and a little bit of
science in this right or a lot of
science in this so there is a utility to
having that identity there is however
ego in it it's like if I want to
convince you that I am an engineer and
that engineers are better than others
and there are rrragh then I'm now trying
to fulfill that endless attempt that
started when I was 6 or actually I was 3
when I started to jump up and down and
say mommy look at me I'm doing this
right I'm now telling mommy and everyone
else hey look at me I'm great I'm
amazing like why why do we try to prove
that much now what if you fix in a
wireframe yeah yeah if you fix the why
you suddenly own your ego but your ego
doesn't own you anymore
right and that is true success is to
realize that ego is a total illusion and
that it will never actually be satisfied
and that it will constantly be a moving
target and that you will never ever feel
you know settled and peaceful as long as
you're chasing ego I I work with and I
you know I I teach solve for happy to
billionaires billionaires right and
they're still bragging to each other
it's like when does it stop right so
they you know they go to Vegas and they
spend half a million dollars each
because Jesus they just want to show
each other that hey I can lose half a
billion dollars can you write they buy
more and more cars not because they need
them but because they want to say look
at me I bought the expensive one and so
on and so forth ego is never satisfied
as long as you're following it you're
gonna follow it for the rest of your
life now the question is can you fix
the why can I come to all of you and say
by the way this is one of the very rare
days where I wore a sheer shirt because
honestly it's cold for me I swear right
I normally wear a $19 t-shirt which by
the way interestingly is another form of
ego that's one of the best exercises is
to eat non expensive food to wear non
expensive things it's that through the
frugal tendency is actually a really
good way to yeah I I just came out of a
full month of fasting in Ramadan right
which is a religious practice but I
believe it's one of my favorite
practices of the year I practice so many
religious you know practices from all
different spiritual beliefs one of them
is one my is one of my favorites which
is Ramadan and Ramadan we fast from
sunrise to sunset so this year it was 19
hours of fasting no water no food for 34
days it reminds you so the 31st day when
you wake up and have a coffee you go
like oh man
that's amazing yeah like seriously it's
like it's just a sip of water at noon
it's like wow and and the whole thing is
that throughout the months you start to
go like so is this what the people is
seven hundred and eighty six million
people around the world who don't have
access to clean waters this how they
feel man I'm so lucky right if you know
you start to remember what hungry people
actually feel you start to really
realize that all you really need is a
bowl of rice and maybe if you're lucky a
tomato and that actually is quite oak
quite okay right and we forget you start
to forget that all you really need is a
$19 t-shirt and by the way maybe four of
them if you're really really doing
overdoing it you might end up with
twenty does that mean you need to be a
billionaire how many $20 t-shirts can
you borrow how many genes can you buy
how many beds can you sleep on and this
isn't it's not just about me you know
I'm not criticizing the material side of
our lives I'm just saying this is one
example
of an illusion that we chase so hard we
spend our entire life trying to achieve
it's never satisfied the ego also helps
us achieve our goals as well so there's
also something nice about our
conscientious ability to set a goal and
to be happy along the journey I'll get
to that goal no no no ego ego prevents
you from achieving your goals first of
all define what your goals are if your
goals are to be happy then ego is
[ __ ] it up completely right because
you'll never be happy chasing an ego
because people are busy chasing their
own egos so they're not what do you use
the sort of goal then is 1 billion happy
about going it's a great goal but huh
but what do you use if not the ego what
is being what are you use to set it so
this is the most interesting discovery I
you know for myself and for my children
and for everyone I start I worked with
for the last 11 years we have a tendency
to be motivated by the negative this is
the way our parents you know raised us
I'm stick I just imagine a stick yes
school school you score an A in school
or score AB or has the test for no
reason other than you're trying to avoid
problems in right you stand in the
street and protest against whatever it
is that you're you know you're you're
against you know why because of hate or
anger or you know disgust or whatever
that is Robert Hansen wrote a great book
about this as well yeah we we we vote to
show our community that yeah we're with
you absolutely yeah
have you ever tried to be motivated by
the positive oh my god it's it's very
different the positive could be the
carrot but that's also a little bit of
very self centered and focused right
like providing value to society so so so
I could stand in in in a in a public
square and protests because of anger for
what's happening in Syria and the people
that are dying or I could stand in the
same place
and protest for compassion for the
people who are suffering so much right
which of them would produce a better
result do you think if I'm angry I will
waste so much time and effort and
tension on my anger and once I release
that anger it's over if it's compassion
I'm actually driven with you know with a
peaceful approach to actually fixing the
problem I have nothing to release I just
want the people to be better
remember Gandhi right was Gandhi the
motivated by hate or motivated by
compassion by you know by peacefulness
by the right things huh yeah if I want
to motivate myself do I have to motivate
myself by you know telling myself that
I'm a horrible person do I have to feel
that I'm bad to become better or can I
actually feel wonderful about what I've
tried to achieve so far and still want
to be better can I love me yeah and
still want to be better that's the words
are they controversy no so so if we
start to learn this one little trick of
I want to be motivated by the positive
right and and there is so much positive
we can have in the world
right there you're my positive is I'm
trying to make by the way a billion
happy it's just a directional target
when you hit ten million and then you
upgrade it to 1 billion yeah but but but
you know what my target is right now to
make you guys happy if that happens
great great day when tomorrow happens
we'll see how many people would show up
right that but but that's a wonderful
measure of success it's a wonderful
measure of success believe it or not and
I know a lot of people misunderstand the
current Google but the Google I joined
hmm Larry and Sergey would always tell
us it's not about the money if you
manage to solve a big problem that
affects the lives of a billion people or
more you're bound to make money yeah you
know Larry used to call it the
toothbrush test if if you managed to
invent the next toothbrush and people
use it twice a day they're probably
gonna pay you some
mmm-hmm right but the focus was can I
actually solve that problem
capitalism took that away so the first
thing we start with is the business plan
how much is there money is there in it
you know how much can we reduce our cost
how much can we increase our revenue we
forgot and the difference between you
solving the problem and making a very
good living like a B Corp approach for
example and just squeezing every cent
out of it is that you're gonna get 999
million dollars more when all you need
is a $20 t-shirt what a waste of life
what a waste of life by the way I'm in
no way I'm in no way saying don't be
filthy rich don't be a hyper influential
don't be extremely powerful
I'm absolutely saying that the biggest
problem we have of our world today is
that the people who chase rich richness
you know wealth Fame and power are not
the best of us if the best of us
become rich become famous become
powerful become influential we would
change the world
so I actually tell people it's your
absolute duty if you're a good person to
become as effective as impactful as you
can in this world yes but when you're
doing it do it out of positivity don't
do it with your unhappiness your stress
as the tax to pay on the path don't do
it from a egotistical hedonistic greedy
perspective do it from bringing utility
to civilization making it a better place
for forever this is something that we
ask a lot on the show and I think you'll
be good to ask you this one yeah it
seems to be that exponential technology
is exacerbating wealth inequality quite
a bit as in the rich are getting very
very very rich and are now able to use
genetic engineering and neural
prosthetics and space colonization and
cryptocurrency and all these different
sorts of means in order to exacerbate
their wealth
and improve their wealth versus the poor
very very very slowly increasing their
wealth across the world what do you
think about a potential class-based
speciation do you have any concerns
about wealth and quality what are they
it's happening you know we so technology
affects our lives in so many ways we
tend to ignore the positives first so
let me talk about the positives we we
have never had a longer life expectancy
in in the modern history of humanity
we've never had you know better
transportation better quality a better
health care better you know quality of
living in general lots of things are so
much better and they're going to
continue to get better yes but we've
also never had so much bullying huh so
we ago a maniacs it's really it's really
crazy and so I when I was growing up I
you know there were two bullies in
school that we had to worry about right
maybe I was one of them I'd never gonna
say that but you know anyway today every
every teenager has to worry about a
billion bully I mean there are all over
the Internet yes
tens of thousands right so so there is
an adverse impact to that now technology
interestingly is just the tool so you
can walk I think at eight kilometres an
hour if you get in a car you can get up
to 280 kilometers an hour
technology is just magnifying our
abilities so it's also magnifying our
problems but it's just the tool I can
use this glass to drink water or I can
hit you on the head where it is is it
the problem of of the glass it isn't the
block the glass is just a tool right
we've abused technology we've also
submitted to a world where we allow
technology players to do whatever they
want and we just submit and go like yes
master we're gonna use it as you're
offering it to us and and I love Apple
right but as long as we keep buying
fancier and fancier phones they're gonna
make fancier and fancier phones right
until we take a stand and we say hey by
the way guys next phone should reduce
the amount of time
I bend my head and look at it you need
to make me more productive you need to
make me happier otherwise I'm not buying
it they're gonna make that happen if we
go to Hollywood and say no more violent
movies they're gonna make comedies right
we don't exercise our rights to choose
okay
put all of that together and then ask
yourself where our world is going our
world has not advanced that's the
problem so we have more toys for the
wrong way but believe it or not if you
truly look at our world today we as
humans hmm we're not advancing at all
we're actually declining we're not
progressing in our own humanity right so
the technology is progressing for
Humanity is declines the climbing so so
the so the reason why we have dating
sites is because we're unable to connect
anymore we're unable to walk out there
and see a wonderful person and walk to
them and say hi right and and so the
calculator the scientific calculator is
helping you solve more math problems
because you're unable to calculate
yourself anymore right the dating site
is hopefully some you know complementing
the weakness that we were developing and
connecting the you know the social media
is trying to give us more virtual
friends because the value of friendship
of every one of them is less than the
true value of us right meeting each
other just hugging each other just
looking each other than others in the
eyes and the problem is becoming massive
and I I don't know how many of you have
seen my 1 billion happy video the
problem is we are at the cusp of handing
over everything we've learned to
machines yes right and and so the
reality is general intelligence AI is
real huh yes III is more than real we're
here in the heart of it huh
general intelligence is 10 to 15 years
away
10 to 15 years time those machines are
going to be smarter than we are
right when they are smarter than we are
we are now going to hand over solving
all of the problems of the world to the
smartest one of us which is not going to
be a noob the challenge is this if they
solve those problems from the same value
system that we have developed in the
last 70 years we're screwed if you go to
them and say solve global warming and it
is about a selfish greedy competitive
position like we have developed over the
last 70 years they're going to say sure
you're the problem right if I get rid of
you
we're going to be all fine right and and
what we need to build instead are
machines that have the value system of
an Indian subcontinent child I actually
use that example quite often you know we
all have Indian subcontinent friends
here who are brilliant they come they
code they develop businesses they become
millionaires or billionaires and then
they go back to take care of their
parents what are their philosophy and
their ethics why that's a great so
understand ethics and values we tend to
believe that ethics our values are like
mysterious they're not if a woman grows
up in Saudi Arabia
she tends to believe that the right way
to fit in is to dress conservatively she
grows up in Brazil she realizes that the
right way to fit in is a g-string right
that is one of them right and the other
is wrong no it's just the general
behavior of the society just like an
artificially intelligent machine we take
as many samples of it as well as we can
and then we say look this kind of
behavior makes people like me that kind
of behavior makes people dislike me so
I'm gonna do that behavior right and
that's what the machines are learning
the problem is if machines look at one
Donald Trump tweet today they're not
going to see any problem if they look at
the one Donald Trump tweet and the
30,000 hate replies below that's a
massive problem yes because to them they
will learn that that's the way we do we
resolve conflict
where we treat each other that's the way
we treat each other so general
intelligence will be developed to say
when someone says something I disagree
with I should thrash them insult them
give them hate speech and not even ask
for what I want just make them feel bad
right great we're being amazing parents
here for our artificially intelligent
children mmm right that needs to change
we need to all have seven and a half
billion conversation about being the
parents to the artificial general
intelligence and that's exactly what
about 1 billion happy is all about so
one you know I don't know how many of
you know the story but this started to
honor my son right I lost my son to
medical malpractice he taught me so much
about happiness and instead of being
motivated by the negative which could be
vengeance against the surgeon or the
hospital I was motivated by the positive
of saying okay this wonderful soul came
into my life he taught me so so much to
honor him I'm gonna teach 10 million
people what he taught me
if I can get 10 million people to
remember him then it doesn't bring him
back but it makes the world a better
place it's a good way instead of saying
a life for a life I said to myself and
his life is not worth one life it's
worth 10 million lives right and those
10 million lives need to be given not
taken right I was amazing
the minute I decided to do that the
whole universe conspired like the whole
world is helping right now being
motivated by that positive then got me
to the point where I've suddenly
realized that if if 10 million is
possible why is a billion not possible
if a billion happens we change the world
yes right now we're in the heart of
technology everyone in this room knows
that the billion is not a big number on
the internet it's not everything I've
ever done at Google rows and billions
right imagine if we have a billion
people that tell the world what our
parents were supposed to teach us our
tried to teach us to be nice to be
polite to be courteous to be generous to
be kind hmm if you just change yourself
just yourself hmm and there as there are
a billion of us out there you know what
will happen we will die in youth the
entire Internet
in two years mm-hmm if you follow a
proper doubling function so I'm using
Moore's law here if we move from where
we are today on 1 billion happy which is
we don't know the exact numbers but the
reach of the videos have been now in the
hundreds of millions we're estimating
that somewhere around 37 million
actually took action right if we keep
doubling every year we get to a billion
happy in five years and the trick is if
we double one more time remember the
exponential function it's two billion
happy on year six now add 2 billion
happy we have the majority of the
internet right it's it's not it's a
crazy task but you know what and I will
say and you know think of me as crazy
but I will tell you if we don't do it
we're toast we're toast
totally toast right we're teaching a
much smarter being to behave as horrible
as we are very bad idea it's a very bad
idea and the behavior change comes from
within absolutely that's the whole game
huh
so one of the most eye-opening
experiences for me was the Arab Spring
right the Arab Spring highlights to you
that one person changes changes two
people they change four people and then
eight million people show up in Tahrir
Square right and and that has been
happening over and over and over on the
web right it's just a matter of me
changing three things
I swear our humanity relies on three
things one is that you realize that you
were born happy it's your absolute
birthright that anyone who told you you
don't deserve to be happy or that it
that happiness is unattainable was lying
right two is that you invest in it just
like you go to the gym to have a good
body how many of us spend
our a day investing in our happiness
watching a video reading a book
spending time with happy people
discussing the topic of happiness just
like we do with everything that we set
our minds to and then number three which
is the most critical part of humanity
today is can we have the compassion in
our heart now that we learned something
about happiness to make another happy
yes if you can make another happy and
make them promise to make another happy
we're gonna get to a billion in five
years it's as simple as that I always
say tell two people who will tell two
people who will tell two people and just
focus on yourself just keep going back
to you and saying okay I'm gonna just
repeat I'm gonna now go back invest
another hour learn something new and
tell to people and tell them to tell to
people right that's it it's a pretty
simple action item it's a very simple
action item it would change our world
now the real question is this how many
of us have experimented with the lie and
noticed that it's not working how many
of us have earned the hundred dollars
they were expecting when they graduated
from school and then said no no no I
want a thousand and then when they got
the thousand they said I want fifteen
and when they got fifty they said I want
a hundred thousand only when I get one
hundred and twenty I'll be happy right
and it never really happens how many of
us have realized that we really inside
because everyone I meet is a good person
believe it or not inside without our
egos were all good people right how many
of us inside are saying I just don't
like the fact that I'm so annoying right
I don't like the fact that I am so so
pretending to be what I'm not I just
want to undress just want to go to work
tomorrow and say look I'm stressed you
know can you go to your manager and say
hey by the way I just don't like this
job can we work together for the next
six months to find me another job and
find you a better person right and
what's the worst that can happen he's
gonna go crazy and fire you if he's that
crazy he doesn't deserve your time
anyway right and you're gonna be fine
you're not gonna start to death it's
it is all of those things that were so
blinded by and we're just moving through
life accepting the the false promise
when it's about time to change
I like the push for daily analysis of
happiness within oneself and then also
within the community yeah that that
that's great
Momo it's a very simple action item that
I think that we can all do are you guys
excited to do that yeah wake you up a
bit get a little conversation rolling
all right all right how about we ask you
about suffering and I wanna you talk a
lot about needless suffering and you
could have easily had a whole life of
needless suffering after what happened
yeah
in the utopia is suffering necessary not
at all okay so what would how do we get
to we've talked about how we do the 1
billion happy if that can become 2
billion happy we can have artificial
general intelligence that it looks at
civilization and learns and there we go
we're good we treat each other well then
if we get to this point of utopia lots
of people talk about suffering being so
valuable to learn from absolute crap
let's see yeah if like unpack absolute
crap I need to go back I promise I'll
come back to the difference between pain
and suffering if I if I don't please ask
me but I need you to understand what
suffering is right so I I struggled with
the idea I was very happy at age 23 I
became very unhappy at age 29 at age 29
I was a director a day trader I was
meeting making a ton of money I was so
wealthy so blessed in every way and I
was clinically depressed I was miserable
and I started to say to myself as an
engineer let's define happiness let's
define what that thing is that I'm
searching for so that at least I can
find it
right and I did it in the most unusual
way I I took as many data points as I
could of moments in my life where I felt
happy I plotted them on charts trying to
find a trend line between them that
trend line that approximates all of the
points in my life I felt happy
the happiness equation now there is one
common thing across every moment in your
life you've ever felt happy right one
common thing across all of the moments
in your life you felt unhappy it has
nothing to do with the absolute event of
your life
so really interestingly every moment in
your life where you've ever felt happy
was a moment where life was seemed to be
going your way
it's as simple as that right you sit in
this room your brain immediately
compares the event to its expectations
of what is a safe model for your
survival it starts to think okay this
room is a little too cold we're going to
be here for two hours is this okay right
that hmm truly is what unhappiness is so
believe it or not happiness there is an
equation happiness is equal to or
greater than the difference between the
events of your life and your expectation
of how life should behave every single
event that crosses your path your brain
solves to see if it meets its
expectations or misses its expectations
right and that gives you a few very
interesting definitions of what
happiness is one is happiness is not fun
it's different going up but you know
jumping up and down and dancing in a
party that's not happiness happiness is
that peaceful feeling you get when
you're okay with life as it is
equanimity yeah it's basically I look at
I mean you all have friends and partners
and people in your life right you can
look at your partner and I can guarantee
or find a girl you'll find a few things
that are amazing and a few things that
perhaps you would have liked to change
right if you look at the things that you
would like to change you're gonna be
unhappy in that relationship yeah right
if you look at them in totality and say
look as they are I'm okay I don't want
to be any other place when you find that
moment you found happiness rain for
example doesn't make you happy or
unhappy rain has no entrance intrinsic
value of happiness if you're a farmer
and you want to plant you know water
your plants rain makes you happy right
if you're you know we're going through
route and we wanna make sure we stop the
fires rain makes us unhappy it makes us
happy if you want a suntan and it rains
you feel unhappy rain has no value of
happiness it's just that comparison
between rain and what you want life to
be these are expectations and indeed so
its events - expectations events -
expectations
now that throws a very interesting
definition of unhappiness unhappiness in
that case is just a survival mechanism
it's a survival mechanism it's your
brain looking at the world around it if
it finds that the world matches its
expectations it does something amazing
it shuts the [ __ ] up right when it shuts
up your default setting as a child is
happy right the problem is if your brain
realizes that this does not match my
expectations it alerts you what does it
alert you in in the form of it alerts
you in the form of emotional pain
emotional pain is I'm worried about the
exam tomorrow that worry is what
triggers me to get up and study I regret
that I said something rude to my friend
that regret makes me call and make a
mess right now
emotional pain is useful unhappiness
isn't unhappiness is a result of pain on
demand right pain on demand like Netflix
of unhappiness it's basically you saying
you know what happened last Friday let
me play that again
AHA and suffer from it and then let me
add a little bit to it right so your
boyfriend says something or girlfriend
says something harsh on Friday you go on
Sunday and say let me remember that and
cry mm-hmm and then on Monday you go
yeah he doesn't love me anymore and then
on Tuesday you say oh damn I hate dating
and then you go like Oh on you on
Wednesday I'm gonna spend the rest of my
life alone and you just can't build as
much drama as you want around it it's
all happened last Friday and by the way
he's not gonna show up and apologize
right so you can be unhappy for as long
as you want until you tell him or her
that you're unhappy nothing's gonna
happen right so what is useful now and
by the way this is this is something I
call the suffering
the suffering cycle is actually quite
straightforward I don't know if you have
one of those friends that wake up in the
morning and feel super excited so they
call you at 8:00 a.m. because they have
been awake since 6:00 and they really
want to tell you something right and so
they call you at 8:00 a.m. you don't
answer so they call at 8:01 you don't
answer so they call at 8:03
and they you don't answer and then they
text you and then they call again and
act like I have to talk to them right
and then at 8:15 you go like can I call
you at 10:00 right and they say sure and
shut up
right that's exactly what your brain
does it tells you hey by the way your
partner said something harsh on Friday
you don't do anything about it so it
makes you feel unhappy and then you
don't do anything about it so your brain
says it again
and so you feel unhappy and you do
nothing about it and so your brain says
it again and again and again and again
is that useful in any way that cycle
wastes your effort wastes your time
waste your energy right and it leads to
nothing at all right it's triggered by
nothing because the event happened last
Friday at least the cortisol which
actually kills you exactly right so so
so so that the reality is that cycle
truly declines your ability to solve the
problem right to actually engage and and
and and that's that's really what why we
say that unhappiness is good for you no
no pain is good for you pain is good for
you because it alerts you that you need
to learn something you need to change
something you need to take action you
need to change direction pain is good
suffering is it so Ali died Ali died
means I could have closed my door and
cried for the rest of my life truly and
if you had hugged Ali once I guarantee
you you wouldn't blame me he was an
angel he was unbelievable he was
everything he was my coach my son I
always say it was my son and my son
right now what good would that be at my
deathbed he would still not be here
right and and I know it sounds really
unfeeling no no I I cry every time I
remember him I I do
but what good is that now suddenly you
start to tell yourself so I feel the
pain and prom I promise you the one
thing that changed my life is I found a
way to take that pain every single
morning and turn it into I'm gonna go
out there and make another thousand
people happy right can you actually do
that can you actually say like the Sun -
right Scott so can you take the pain
because pain is coming from outside you
and instead of turning it into incessant
thinking that just tortures you turn it
into energy that makes the world a
better place
and and I have clear examples of that
every morning I have a very simple deal
with my brain I have a deal that says
target a deal oh it's really
straightforward you have you have to
understand this the thoughts in your
head are not you right the thoughts in
your head are a biological function this
is your brain producing and a concept
that you can understand in English am i
safe do I have food at leap it's
basically processing everything there is
an MIT study that is incredible you
should look at it 2009 it had MRI
studies giving people word puzzles right
and they basically asked them to solve
problems the problem was solved in a few
seconds based on how complex the problem
is and then the verbal Association
engine of your brain the part that
actually lights up when you speak out
loud starts to blink for up to eight
seconds and then the participant would
know the answer so the brought the brain
actually solves the problem first and
then takes eight seconds to turn it to
English so that you understand it right
it's a biological function home how many
of you wake up every morning and tell
yourself I am blood you know the
biological function of your heart is to
pump blood around your body you don't
call yourself blood no one calls
themselves urine right seriously you
know biological function of your kidney
but somehow we think that the thoughts
in my head are me talking to me if it
was you talking to you what why would
you need to talk like seriously right
now one once you realize that everything
changes right so I have a very clear
deal with my brain as a third party my
brain is a third party
so it's allowed to give me only two
types of thought the third it gets
kicked out of my room right and comes
back with a better thought so my brain
can bring me a joyful thought or a
useful thought mmm right if the if the
if the thought is joyful we will go
along with it if it's not I will stop it
right so every morning I wake up and my
brain will tell me I'm not making this
up I love that boy so much every morning
I will wake up and my brain will say
iodide and every morning I will wake up
and deliberately say no brain Ali lived
and he lived is the same thought but
when I when I remind my brain that had
he lived I get 21 and a half incredible
years of all of the wonderful moments
that we spent together it's the same
thought like Ali died but I did I'd
would bring his image in the end the
intensive-care rule mm-hmm I don't want
that image because it's useless it's the
21 years of bliss that you had and then
what you're doing with it now that the
drives that the staff use the same
thought but there's a different outcome
and the outcome is so different the
outcome is so different when when you
when you lead your brain as a third
party suddenly your brain does amazing
things so same applies to useful salsa
when Ali died my brain started to say
every single minute for the next four
hours it had one thought repeating over
and over and over
you should have driven him to another
hospital until I allowed out loud I told
myself what can I do with that brain
mm-hmm what can I do with that thought
can I go back and drive him to another
hospital now can you please go back and
find me a better thought just like I'm
talking to a third party a friend who's
constantly complaining right and and and
my brain was like okay let me think
about that right four days later it came
back and said hey what about if we share
his model with ten million people and
make them happy what would would that be
a good thought yeah like yeah I'll take
that
let's do it right that's a great thought
and does it bring him back it does not
bring him back understand this
you have a contract with your brain to
not allow needless suffering absolutely
don't waste my life and by the way I
learned that as an executive right so
people would walk into my room and
complain and you know being courteous I
listened for the first 10 minutes and
then after 10 minutes what do good
executives say they say okay what's good
about this situation right or what can
we do about it
what you want me to change what actions
can we take right and once you do that
the person on the other side now that
they vented a little they will say well
you know but I also like this and maybe
we shouldn't change that and but maybe
we should do this great that's the kind
of thought that we want incessant
thinking is useless it's just
complaining ok let's let's power through
a couple questions and then let's get to
the Q&A first question is what do you
think happens after death oh that's not
an easy question I do not know the
answer to that ok but I know that we
don't we never really die I know that
was science I'm so so understand this
huh
I'm dead center between EQ and IQ but
I've learned through the modern world to
prioritize my IQ to proper prioritize
logic right and so every single thing I
say in solve for happy and all of my
lectures or teachings or whatever I
avoid going to my spiritual side because
I want to remain objective there are so
many people in the world that can talk
about things from a spiritual point of
view I want to be the objective one that
talks about it from science I I don't
know if we have the time for this but if
you truly understand the theory of
relativity if you truly understand
space-time continuum if you truly
understand that time does not really
exist in the form that we understand it
does you have to start questioning who
died first me or Allie who lived first
in your alley
first or last is a property of the
physical it's a property of this
physical world
if space-time continuum exists and I can
actually perceive time that must mean I
have a vantage point that stays with
outside time a vantage point is a
prerequisite to perception I cannot
perceive this building if I'm inside it
for me to perceive this building I have
to be outside it for us to see planet
Earth we had to send people outside or
machines outside right if you're within
time you wouldn't perceive that the
reason why we perceive the arrow of time
is because we reside outside space-time
their real us resides outside case
space-time and and most of us don't
realize that they still us oh yeah this
is the avatar this is the avatar this
truly is the avatar this vehicle this me
this is this is the the vehicle that you
the physical vehicle you use to navigate
the physical form the physical world
right it's the avatar that you're
sitting somewhere else with the control
right otherwise you wouldn't perceive
any of this you could not perceive it if
you're inside it the other side of it
huh if you if you combine quantum
physics with with the Big Bang Theory
you start to realize the simplest things
that science ignores to mention for some
reason we how big banks has 13.7 billion
years ago there was a tiny mass that
compressed enough and then exploded into
gases and then condensed into planets
and other objects right 4.3 billion
years ago there was planet Earth it
cooled down and then over portfolio of
you know I think 3.9 billion of those
years there was no life and then life
started to show or whatever the numbers
are please don't quote me on the numbers
but they're within those ranges quantum
physics on the other hand will tell you
that nothing actually exists in its
particle form until observed so who was
observing this for the first thirteen
billion years life has always existed
somehow in some form
so what I can tell you is this with
certainty that death is not the opposite
of life death is the opposite of birth
you come into this world through a
portal that we call birth you leave this
physical form through a portal that we
call death but life exists before during
and after right now when you think about
it this way you realize that what died
is my son's physical form and you know
what is the only thing that is certain
unless you'll find the miracle somehow
is that I will die too
okay this physical form will go to the
only certainty is that wherever Allie is
now I will be too right whatever that is
and the journey between now and then
might be a year ten twenty thirty in the
absence of time and the relativity of
time it will go like this
and we all know that I'm you know you
just look back at your last thirty years
and ask yourself how quickly they passed
now blink of an eye blink of an eye now
fast and hopefully there's more life
after the portal of so so what happens
after is really where I somehow blame
spirituality because some of them will
say with certainty it's reincarnation
others will say with certainty it's life
you know heaven and hell and we don't
have proof of that but does it really
matter
if you're a video gamer and you know
that at the end of the game the console
or at the end of the level the concert
is going to blink a little bit it's the
screen is gonna go dark and then you're
going to go to another level
or maybe the game will end hmm does it
make any difference to the way you play
this level this is the level you're in
play it as best as you can
yes right and and regardless of what
happens on the next level if you know
the enemies will have bigger armors or
there will no not be enemies or suddenly
the game will be over and you'll put the
controller down does it really make any
difference to the way you play this
level the way you play this level is to
become the absolute best gamer you can
become
yeah and that's truly the whole trick if
we manage to stop thinking about the
next level or actually just the next
move on the in the game and just focus
on this move yeah everything becomes
easy in this piggy backs this world
rides right into the question we asked
on the show a lot which is do you think
we're in a simulation what difference
does it make
dude why do I think we're in a
simulation define a simulation if you
really define a simulation absolutely
we're in a simulation right so none of
what you see is actually what you see
none of what you touch is actually what
you touch we don't touch anything you
realize that you've never touched
anything in your life the molecular
forces
how can you touch one really the mass in
this skin I'm sure you understand that
so so the entire mass in your body is
probably a pin size and the rest space
the rest is elect electrons
you know orbiting the nuclei and you
know you know at a very large distance
and the reason why you can touch is
because there is you know force here and
force there and they just cannot
interact right if I really look at you
it's actually quite interesting I see
you inside of myself absolutely so so
the reality is you do you're not here
you're mostly empty space
but the photons hitting your head are
just slightly smaller than the distance
is slightly bigger so they reflect right
so they reflect to my eye they trigger
an electrical signal that gets
translated into my brain as you know a
wonderful elegant shirt right but is
that really a shirt is that really
something is you know does a cat see it
the same way will the artificially
intelligent machines you see it the same
way of course not and so the reality is
that this entire world we live in is
just an electrical signal in your brain
which is not very different different
from halo near just saying right it's
just but but it doesn't have to be a
video game it doesn't have to be a
simulation it just operates
suspiciously similar to a videogame that
there is some grand designer of the game
and that there is maybe multiple grand
designers maybe you do have a controller
and when you get go through the portal
of death then you jump into controlling
another avatar and how many of your
memories you remember from your previous
avatars who knows this exciting stuff mo
one last question is what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
well it's the only thing in the world
the truth I think the most beautiful
thing in the world is the truth and I
tend to believe that we're all here in a
in a quest that's never gonna be
fulfilled to constantly seek what that
is which is a quest that starts with
finding out what's not true because in
reality the only method you can ever get
to something that remotely simulates the
truth or represents the truth is to at
least find out what is it okay and and
my entire work as a matter of fact even
half of what I'm working on now is that
is an attempt to show you how much of an
illusion we live in and believed to be
true and if you just strip the illusions
one by one what's left behind is the
truth so it's a quest that will take the
rest of my life and I can guarantee you
I'm never gonna find it but it's so
interesting to just find out what isn't
one by one and when we truly know the
extent of our ignorance it's easier to
find out what's not the truth yeah we
are we're pretty ignorant we know
nothing at all we know nothing at all
true and we'll help you here we will
help you get to 1 billion happy and from
there it will be easier to train the
artificial general intelligence I hope
so yeah you guys promised so you promise
yeah we promised ok great
mo thank you for the conversation first
there's one to give let's give a big
round of applause
[Applause]
yeah
you